sun goes down hundreds of people prepare
to leave as fighting intensifies in the
south of ukraine
under the cover of darkness a ferry full
of cars carrying people and their
belongings crosses the danube river into
romania
the coast guard escorts them to safety
i came from odessa we planned to leave
on sunday we knew there was a curfew for
the day so my family and i decided to
leave because it's the first time
there's a day-long curfew in the village
even family pets are welcomed here
alongside her mother this little girl is
seemingly unaware of the danger she's
fled
it's war of course it's war yesterday a
rocket flew above our house and exploded
it's very scary children are scared
that's why we're leaving
volunteers from abroad like this man
from the u.s greet the weary travelers
and help prepare food and warm places
for them to sleep
he says most people he's helped are
women and children we've been to about
eight different centers where we've
delivered food
just today we purchased a couple of
washing machines for one of the centers
because one of the greatest needs has
been
being able to wash the clothes and so we
were able to help with that as well
this is the first time these ukrainians
have been made refugees
many here say they plan to return home
once the fighting stops leah harding al
jazeera